even deals um where labels will want a
piece of if you start a clothing line
while you're signed yep that they can
somehow figure out was from the music
they want a piece of it this this just
happened to a friend of mine who my
boy's got a really big clothing line I
mean it's huge he had signed a deal
probably 2012
2013 and there was actually a discussion
that he might have to give up some of
his clothing line yeah and I understand
some of the terms for um an artist that
you take from nothing who like no one
knows this [__] and all of a sudden
everyone those people aren't getting
deals though I under they're getting
three they are are they they just
getting three they're getting it it's a
all encompassing deal because they're
making they're making your brand but to
take a [__] who's coming in who's
already selling out shows and selling
tickets and selling Stu and say oh we
want the it's just like you're [__]
insane
you don't even have an artist on your
roster that's at the level that I'm at
but you want those things so there are
situations in which you could see a 360
deal benefi an artist I think a 360 deal
is hyper beneficial if you're a
businessman like if you cuz every artist
don't have streaming but some of us I
did half a million on my own shows last
year not counting outside performances I
do half a million on merch so if you're
able to leverage those things in
exchange for Capital
outside of the streaming I don't think
that's a bad deal I think that's a great
if you go partner with anyone and you
say hey I love your business I want to
percent I'll put all this money up
that's not a bad thing that's what every
[__] startup company tech company
does it's I think it's a bad thing when
it's
like when you don't give a [__] the
amount of funds to actually build it or
the infrastructure and resource to
actually build it and you're just going
to take it it's a little different it's
a little more it's a little offputting
or if you if if it's someone who's
already established all this [__] and
you're not giving them the the means of
capital to excel it but you want to take
it as just like bro you got to
contribute to get out of that [__] I
heard uh did you ever see the leor Cohen
interview he explained the 360 deal yeah
so he kind of explained it is if you and
I start a restaurant together and I'm
the investor M and and you start taking
the sauce that's popping and selling it
at Walmart do I get a piece of the sauce
and I I understood it from that angle
and like you said like if you're an
artist who doesn't have a cult following
doesn't have a brand doesn't really have
anything going maybe a little Tik Tok
moment maybe it is worth it it makes so
much sense because in the machine you'll
get on the other side of that deal
eventually and that it'll help you
recoup faster MH it'll help cuz product
sells way faster than music right so
you'll be able to recoup and be out your
situation way faster if it aligns like I
say if someone's helping you build all
those those revenues like if you don't
have a merch business going and someone
says oh I I'll help you make a million
dollars in merch yeah I think they
should have a yeah if you to do that
[__] standard for every [__] that comes
in this office you just offer it to him
it's like like some of my issues with
some of the deals I got is like I'll
give a proposal and they ask what I want
and I'll get the contract back and it's
a bunch of [__] that we didn't even
discuss it's like you don't you don't
just throw something in a [__] contract
without
like they be like yo they be to so much
[__] into these bills that are supposed
to be about something else and you like
really read like wait what we F what
right no that's some real [__] it's
crazy because um I do feel like you know
if there's anybody who can kind of lead
a real change in Renaissance into how
this is thought of um I think it's you
man because I've SE I'm seeing it I saw
Curtis King post his [__] from even what
is even so even is a uh
an all- incompetent platform eventually
is going to grow to an artist Hub where
are part of it or you yeah I have Equity
okay so you have Equity even I've been
seeing people post their the very first
launch of Spotify Recaps this what I did
hilarious yeah man even as an all-
incompetent platform for artists like we
just give artists the ability to
monetize and sell their music if they
don't have their own situation some some
artists don't have a Shopify setup or
just want to have a website and all that
[__] and even makes it easy for the fans
to come support and buy your music
directly from you what's the play so my
whole thing with the with the third
party [__] right is we're so conditioned
to play music on certain apps so if I
buy an album on
even it's it's set up just like Spotify
it's an inapp streamer so it's so I'll
download the even app on my phone right
so if I any based it's web based so it's
not so that's what y got to figure out
eventually it'll that's that for as a
fan for Fan Experience purposes right
that's what you want you want to be able
to be like oh cool I got my even library
of all the [__] I've supported yeah
definitely and I I believe he built a
web base based off like data that people
were still kind of going online for
specific and it's like even was really
built from the dirt a year ago like I
just did the very first launch last year
when I did 100,000 on that album that
was the first anybody's heard of it in
existence and I campaigned the whole to
pay offer like this [__] was built from
the dirt and in one year we've gotten
omaran and dizzy RS and a bunch of major
labels are on boarding now like the
majors are going to even so they can run
their upcoming all I wonder like uh cuz
yeah I wish I feel like if I was an
upand cominging artist I would want to
have that option like is that we get
worked into my deal where like yo if I
want to be able to you guys might get a
cut of this but right I want to be able
to sell my [__] right for maybe well I
mean a lot of artists see when you going
into the major system it's so different
cuz it's very hard to sell music that
you don't own it
is straight up very hard yeah you got to
ask permission right